bonjour katia vous êtes dans le cortège
est ce que cet appel à la mobilisation a
été entendu
oui alors vraiment entendu puisqu'il ya
au moins dix mille personnes pas
vraiment de 7,6 site officiel pour le
moment mais le cortège est très très
impressionnant et nous sommes
actuellement en train de remonter la rue
lafayette ou la descente plus
précisément pour en rejoindre la place
de l'opéra alors vous savez c'est une
intersyndicale interprofessionnelle à
l'appel de fo la cgt fsu solidaires et
d'organisations de jeunesse organisation
étudiante et donc il y à de nombreuses
revendications ici notamment la hausse
des salaires est évidemment un stop
demandées concernant la réforme des
retraites je suis actuellement et jake
bernstein secrétaire adjoint de force
ouvrière à paris alors monsieur
borenstein aujourd'hui c'est une
mobilisation très suivie c'est aussi une
interprofessionnelle il n'avait pas eu
depuis un moment ça veut dire quoi
écoutez la dernière mais si on met à
part le 1er mai la dernière fois où une
manifestion dans cette configuration en
interprofessionnelle salariés du public
comme du privé c'est la fin du débat sur
les retraites en février mars juste
avant le début de la crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui avec la crise sanitaire qui
n'est pas encore fini mais on s'est
enfoncé dans la précarité de nombreuses
personnes s'enfuir a écrit qualité que
ce soit les salariés les jeunes et
toutes les raisons sont là aujourd'hui
de manifester pour exiger à la fois
l'abandon des réformes nocifs comme
celle des retraites celle de l'assurance
chômage mais également augmenter les
salaires pour retrouver des revenus
décents alors qu'aujourd'hui les profits
du cac 40 ne font qu'augmenter alors
justement vous êtes là aussi pour mettre
l'accent sur ces augmentations de
salaires et les négociations qui ont
lieu en ce moment pour trouver des
accords de branche ça se passe comment
exactement
les négociations devraient avoir lieu je
prends l'exemple de l'hôtellerie tout le
monde la ministre la chambre patronale
tout le monde nous dit qu'il faut
augmenter les salaires mais pour
l'instant on ne voit rien venir donc
qu'on en parle c'est bien mais surtout
ce qu'on voudrait maintenant c'est que
ça arrive en bas de la fiche de paye à
droite donc aujourd'hui ça veut dire que
vous êtes plus que jamais mobilisés pour
faire pression au moment où il pourrait
y avoir quelque chose on est mobilisé
pour faire pression bien sûr sur les
salaires mais sur l'arrêt de toutes les
contre réformes et aujourd'hui non
seulement les salaires ne sont pas
augmentés on en parle mais de plus la
réforme de l'assurance chômage frappe de
plein fouet ceux qui sont déjà
précarisées et super précarisés par les
conséquences de la crise sanitaire est
il votre demande sur un la réforme des
retraites évidemment vous êtes content à
nous on est pour l'abandon pur et simple
de la réforme de retraites on n'a pas
varié on est pour le maintien de
l'ensemble des régimes aujourd'hui et le
rapport du cor d'ailleurs le comité
d'orientation des retraites nous dit que
d'ici 2040 tout naturellement
l'equilibre reviendra or on sait que au
bénéfice de la crise sanitaire et des
milliards et des milliards qui ont été
distribués beaucoup ont été puisés dans
les caisses sociales de la sécurité
sociale des retraites de la sécurité
sociale en général avec un quelque chose
qui est
c'est
surréaliste c'est qu'on a aujourd'hui
moins de lits dans les hôpitaux qui
avant la crise sanitaire donc c'est plus
possible de continuer avec cette
politique il faut avec thé avec cette
politique régressive redonner la place
ou services publics à ce qu'ils
travaillent mais aussi revaloriser
l'ensemble des carrières dans le privé
et le gouvernement ne donne pas
l'exemple puisque aujourd'hui le point
d'indicé dans la fonction publique est
toujours bloquée non seulement on nous
fait des réformes pour détecter le
statut des agents de la fonction
publique mais les salaires eux sont
toujours bloqués l'état ferait mieux au
lieu de parler
les conseils de donner un signe en
augmentant les salaires des
fonctionnaires merci beaucoup zac
borenstein nous suivons bien sûr la
situation ici alors que le cortège très
impressionnant se dirigea vers la place
de l'opéra et au ventre au bout donc
tout à leur merci beaucoup katia
technique